[Music]
so if you don't know
uh
facebook bought
instagram several years ago i was at
2013 maybe something like that 2014.
bought them for like a billion dollars
facebook realized that they were
becoming the place where old people
complain about everything
they trade preparation h recipes and
scream about politics at one another and
where they thumbs down each other and
they're
i don't know they make signs and quips
and pass along bad science and stupid
stuff
and so they bought instagram where the
kids were flocking to
and as any good company does they do
they do market testing on how their
product is working how it's being
received how the end user is
experiencing their products
and what are some challenges moving
forward what are some um
opportunities moving forward a little
swollen swot analysis and if you've seen
in the news facebook was working on
instagrams working on a product for
under 13 year olds
what's an instagram product for kids for
children
then this article in the wall street
journal comes out we'll link to it in
the show notes
the title is by georgia wells jeff
horwitz and deepa
sitharaman
facebook knows instagram is toxic for
teen girls company document show
here's a couple of excerpts
32 percent of teen girls said that when
they felt bad about their bodies
instagram made their them feel worse
this is from internal research that they
did on their own product inside their
company
from i don't know how this thing was
leaked but it was internal research
documents presented to employees
including the executives
comparisons on instagram can change how
young women view and describe themselves
these are internal documents
one of the internal documents said we
make body image issues worse for one in
three teen girls
as they summarize research about teen
girls who experience the issues teens
blame instagram for increases in the
rate of anxiety and depression body
image issues
and this reaction was unprompted and
consistent across all groups among teens
who reported suicidal thoughts
13 of british users and 6 of american
users traced the desire to kill
themselves to instagram
one internal presentation
slide showed
and this article goes on and on and on
features that instagram identifies as
most harmful to teens appear to be at
the platform's core
these are not peripheral things
these are core to how instagram works
how the algorithms work how it uses
pictures and pithy little sayings and
how it
uses
full bodies instead of like tick-tock
focuses on faces or on feeling like
the core presentation of instagram is
hurting kids
in august senators richard blumenthal
and marsha blackburn in a letter to mark
zuckerberg called on him to release
facebook's internal research on the
impact of its platforms on young on
youth mental health
in response facebook sent the senators a
six-page letter that didn't include
anything about the company's own studies
instead it said we are not aware of a
consensus among studies or experts about
how much screen time is too much
totally dodged it in fact when they said
we want to see your research that you
have done on your products on how it's
affecting kids
they said well we don't know of any
studies out there
thanks for the thanks for the inquiry
remember when
cancer
when uh smoking
tobacco producers had all those studies
on cancer
and they said oh crap and they buried
them
and as several more companies are coming
to the forefront
[Music]
they're buying their own scientists
they're hiring scientists and then
they're doing their own internal
research not relying on university
labs often
because university labs are publicly
funded
and that means the results both good and
or bad are in the public sphere
and so if i just hire my own scientists
do my own internal data my own internal
research i own all the results which
means i can take the bad ones and put
them in a shredder
that means if i'm creating the next new
diet supplement
and it kills people or gives them rocket
diarrhea or they lose eight hundred
pounds and cognitive function
but i find one study of the twenty i did
that says oh my name they lost
.0420.02 percent body fat when they took
this supplement i can say
research backs that this thing works and
i can take all 19 other studies and put
in the drawer
that's what's happening here
man
some of the researchers jonathan heights
said i asked mark zuckerberg to help us
out as parents
and mark said i'm working on it
here's the thing
i promise you
i promise you
both from my personal experience from
the data that ever increasing data
that is coming out in study after study
after study after study
that handing kids a smartphone and
saying make good choices
is going to have dramatic negative
effects
what your kids are desperate for is you
and human connection
and friends
not curated
imaginary
worlds that look real and that make them
feel worse about themselves that make
them want to not exist anymore
in the company
i'll say plural the companies that are
creating this
no
they know
and it's just a matter of time and we're
all gonna say ugh we knew better
i'm calling on his parents let's do it
differently
let's
be
different
it's my friend nathan
and i we
are always back and forth
be the only one
be the first and only parent in your
little circle that says you know what
we're just taking this crap away from
our kids
we're taking it away
we're gonna make our kids communicate
with real people
they can zoom their friends in the
living room
but they're not gonna be on these
platforms just rolling scrolling
scrolling scrolling scrolling parents
connect with your kids
take the screens away take the apps away
the social media away stop stop stop
you can disagree with me on that i'd
love to hear your disagreements write me
your emails let me know that i'm wrong
and i'm crazy i'd love to hear it
i've not seen one compelling research
study one compelling interaction with a
child who made me think you know what
i'm wrong i should give my kids all my
kids social media
they're seven they should have tick tock
you're right they are nine they should
be on instagram yeah you know what i
need to get my kids
twitter that's probably a smart idea i
haven't seen one
i haven't seen one
i've seen a bunch of exhausted parents
myself included who are just like you
know what i'm i might i'm whatever i'm
gonna watch netflix i'm tired do
whatever you're gonna do make good
choices
and appearance is not enough anymore
it's not enough anymore let's do right
by our kids